you
[Music]
I sure to introduce madhu Parthasarathy
who's visiting us from Illinois
University of Illinois urbana-champaign
he's been doing research in logics and
decision procedures for program
verification building verified systems
of ladies doing synthesis and using
machine learning to infer invariants and
so today is going to talk about national
proofs and quantify instantiation okay
so I'm going to talk about this work
which we the results are fairly new so
there are the slides are raw and the
results also a bit raw in the sense that
we probably haven't understood the you
know consequences of a results
completely to present it in a nice way
okay so with that caveat this work is a
joint work with Christophe luding at our
wth and Lucas pena was a student at
University of Illinois so I'm going to
be sticking to this this verification
context just deductive verification the
problem is you have a program let's say
with assertions that you need to that
you want to prove correct and the method
we're going to follow is annotated with
strong enough inductive pre and post
conditions and loop invariants and then
we generate verification conditions
which involve loop free code and this
will be in the underlying logic what can
vary and then we want to use validate
the verification conditions using a
logic solver so what logic to be used
for these specifications right actually
this quite a lot of choices right the
first kind of logics that come to mind
our first-order logic right so but as we
will see this is not quite enough but
traditionally you know if you really
want to automate everything then you
would you would like to verification
conditions to be
essentially in a decidable logic right
and so if it's quantifier free or the
logic that I decide about then then that
will be fully automated oh and the idea
is that this quantifier free logics with
some background theories especially you
know if their quantifier free then they
are combined able if they're this meet
some conditions they're combined able
using Nelson open and that gives you a
wide variety of theories that you could
use and build decision procedures that
are in kind of independent of each other
now the attraction of death decidable
logics is that verification after an
annotation is fully automated right and
that is actually quite useful because
when you are actually verifying right
you know that you'll either get back
well time is one thing but you'll get
back either an error or you know it
won't just keep on searching if it keeps
on searching then I don't know whether
it's it's actually maybe I wrote
something wrong right and there is
there's a little bit of uncertainty when
you use the verification tool when you
don't have decidable logics but I think
the decidability can also be a trap
right we need to we need powerful enough
logics right to do program verification
right and and I think the at least the
natural logics that we can use to
express properties that we want to prove
right will you know turn out to be
undecidable right so for instance we do
need quantifiers
we need logics perhaps over certain
theories that are undecidable right
and typically currently I would say the
the the the you know the reasons why we
need more expressive power than
decidable logics are the state
properties about unbounded parts of your
program configuration like arrays and
data structures and the dynamically
changing heap or to express and even if
you if you kind of go away from you know
this by assuming certain libraries which
late state and keep these structures for
you in some abstract way you still need
to you need to argue about sequences
sets you know functions odd recursive
functions of your of your data structure
and so on and these are typically not
going to be in decidable theories so so
there is this obsession with
decidability and I've been part of that
we've been trying to work with decidable
logics as much as possible and
decidability as I said when you when you
when achievable is very good right you
can you can actually use your
predictability it also gives you
engineering of efficient tools because
you can have competitions and you don't
have things which I think it's a little
harder to have a competition with on
some things you're gonna fail even
proving right
I think it kind of directs the
engineering task better when you know
it's a decidable problem it's more like
a heuristic for building better tools
right you kind of guides you but and
when we have found that to be the case
that you know over time we've got better
solvers with decidable logic so that's
that's definitely a we don't know how
these mechanics work and never better
but it seems to be true I don't know if
well it depends on what you call
predictable I think you have a lower bar
for predictability them what sense of
achievement is the variance greater
if you keep doing runs with different
random seeds on undecidable
so this agenda of building decidable
theories right the ultimate question is
you know can we overtime really obtain a
powerful enough decidable logic using
which we can prove all that we need to
right and I think that question is not
it's not clear right I mean everyone
makes a an epsilon step does one more
decidable logic which is slightly more
powerful it's not clear where this whole
thing is headed so in my view the answer
seems to be no right I don't think we
are heading towards the wonderful you
know decidable logics that will solve
all the verification problems that's
what I think it's not this like you know
for but they're often incompatible right
because they incompatible as well well
typically you kind of branch out you
know maybe I ain't comparable and then
it'll kind of merge and sometimes you do
get reasonably robust things you want to
design the logic for your verification
conditions but the verification
conditions yeah it depends on the proof
you do yes that's a really saying you
want to be able to get your approved by
some manual steps down to the disciple
fragment is easily as possible
in which case you can never really say
you solved the problem you just say yes
I'm being vague here so I I hope that's
okay I'm not being any I'm not making
any concrete say because I'm just trying
to motivate natural proofs right which
is a different way of looking at things
so there are the statements America make
are going to be a little big at this
point okay so we worked on decidable
logics for heaps for a long time right
and we had this logical strand and there
been lots of logics for heaps right and
their logics also based on separation
logics for heats right several decidable
fragments have emerged right but I don't
see this part towards a powerful enough
logic right
just also decidable right so so to two
things which i notice is that as the
Lord as you get more and more expressive
in your logic right the constraints yet
you need to put in your syntax become
more and more awkward right you're not
allowed not just given a set of
operators and say combine whatever you
want no no no you should have some some
you know bizarre conditions that need to
be satisfied the second thing which I
find is more troubling is that the
decision procedures get more and more
complex right by that I mean that even
if you had something which you could
solve earlier right and you through that
the new decision procedure which handles
a larger logic right it takes much
longer to do that same problem the same
instance right so the the general way of
solving something right makes the
procedures tend to work slower right
they they have to solve a larger class
of problems more uniformly and so you
get they seem to at least in our our
experience strand I know you start using
all kinds of background things like
monadic signal logic and stuff like that
it start stitching these things up to
get more expressiveness and then they
work really bad here and even simple
instances right and I think one should
remember that decidability is a
heuristic here automation is the goal
not not decidability is not the goal
right so here's the here's their other
way of looking at it which I've been
working on for several years right the
idea in decidable logics is that you
want to you want to curtail your
expressive power of your logic so that
it becomes automatable right automate
reasoning right now natural proofs the
idea is different is that you allow a
logic to be quite powerful right
you might restrict the style but you
don't typically restrict the expressive
power right but instead of and in order
to automate what you do is you look for
a subclass of proofs right and these
proofs are going to be
you know simpler to search for right and
if you find a simple proof for your
theorem you're gonna say yes I found it
and if you don't find a proof then it's
it's not going to work right so you're
going to give up right so these are more
like sound and complete ways but
incomplete ways right of solving
problems right but we'd like to be built
robust classes nevertheless right and
possibly even a hierarchy of classes I
look for the simplest proofs and if I
don't find it I kind of enlarge my by
the class of proofs I search for so two
things is a logic doesn't get awkward
right you write what you want right
given the style and the proofs are not
going to get complex because I'm going
to kind of search for simple proofs only
no sir typically so you let you search
for simple proof you don't find it like
qualify instantiation is one right
you could quantify more right you can
instantiate more that's that's does it
mean no it's just it's justice it's
definition wise it's simple to to to
search for a proof of that kind right
the complexity of searching for a proof
of that kindness - right so but it's
going to be a subclass of proof
something that's them that's the main
main thing right okay so so we've been
working on natural proofs for some time
and this is not practice as an industry
practice right it's basically trying to
work on make this work on a set of
benchmarks so so what we have settled on
is really first-order logic right with
recursive definitions and background
theories right and we have found that
this is good enough to express
properties about heaps so
so we have a we have a variant of a
dialect of separation logical triad that
compiles into this logic right I don't
know how to how to do automation on
separation logic or other logics
directly I know only classical logic so
I'm going to stick to classical logic
right so but we do have more than
first-order logic we do have further
logic with recursive definitions right
and and the heuristics that we use to
find to prove prove a theorem are what
we found in practice people do right if
you give it automatic to a manual II to
a person to prove it right what tactics
would they use and typically what they
use in the world of recursive definition
is unfold with recursive definitions
right typically a few times right and
then they do some kind of unification
right at a level of term rewriting you
can think of this unification but it's
basically you can kind of mimic this as
interpreting the recursive definitions
that you have as uninterpreted functions
right that kind of mimics the the
quality of the unification things that
they do right so we look at proofs of
how people normally prove things right
and the simple truths are really based
on this right this was enough to prove
most of the things and so resulting
formulas so what we do is basically
unfold the recursive definitions if I
have a recursive definition of a list I
will just unfold it a few times right
and then I would basically interpret the
recursive definitions as uninterpreted
functions right and I'm in a refutation
based context so I'm looking at a
formula and trying to prove it's valid
by showing its negation is unsatisfiable
right so if doing this already gives me
a mere unsatisfiable formula I'm done
because I've shown that the theorem is
valid right so I don't need to actually
unfold this is a introducing abstraction
but this abstraction is fine right and
kind of mimics what people do moreover
the resulting formulas are actually in
decidable theories right so you can
unsold and then send it off to an SMT
solver
by the way this is not at all you know
that only we do everyone essentially
does this right natural proofs is more
like a name for you know talking about
this in some way but Daphne does it
right if you have recursive definitions
and Daphne which are pure functions
Daphne unfold these functions and gives
it to the assembly salsa right everyone
does it got to do with yeah you could
you could think about it that way but
it's basically the fact that you're
abstracting from what you want to prove
right and thereby you're looking for a
simpler proof that that thing holds
right so if you don't succeed in this
doesn't mean that it doesn't hold you
don't get concrete counter examples or
anything like that right maybe maybe
that the theorem is false or maybe you
need to do more right something for an
object in the heap how much of the rest
of the he really care about right right
so if it's so the the variant of Dryad
actually has it it forces you to write
recursive definition so that you don't
rely on something very far away right so
typically recursive data structures you
can you can have the quantification
restrict in a guarded fashion so that it
refers only to something that you
already have in your hand right and so
dry it actually does all that so you
should make sure that you don't do
arbitrary quantification so that they
are more amenable to recursive recursive
proofs inductive proof so here's an
example so I have the definition of a
list here right either it's nil and the
heap let of this list is empty I don't
really need this right or the X is not
nil and the next element to X is a list
and X does not belong to the he plat
containing this list in the next of the
list so this is a this is the way you
would do in separation logic right I'm
just writing it using first-order logic
and H list is defined using again
recursion
the empty set of X's nil or it's X Union
this now this turns out to properly
define lists right if H list however
makes sense only is X points to list
otherwise you shouldn't use it it may it
may be spurious right but in the
intended semantics is at least fixed
point semantics right so we need
first-order logic with least 6 points to
express these kind of properties right
and we are using background theories
here it sets right I'm using Union and
so on right but once I unfold things
then this will actually be in a
desirable theory because the this kind
of theory of sets is decidable
so the question we wanted to ask was why
do these natural proofs work so well
right when they do right and why do they
fail so miserably on simple properties
so they don't actually work well all the
time ok there are very simple properties
on which they don't work well and is
there any completeness theorem we can
prove about the simple heuristic that we
have right that is if he unfolded the
definitions larger and larger can we
prove every theorem for example okay so
so what we have now is a set of terms
where we can we can answer such
questions all right so this has got to
do with quantify instantiation right now
it turns out that unfolding recursive
definitions is really very similar to
quantify instantiation done which is
formula-driven quantify instantiation
for in for instance if I have this
definition of Liss right it's so
unfolding this for you know one more
time which is next of X right I want to
write the definition for next of X then
it's the same as replacing X with next
of X in this definition right so
unfolding is really like taking this
universally quantified variable X and
instantiating with something else which
is another term
which could be n of X now formula-driven
quantify instantiation is a common
strategy for handling Universal
quantification it's incomplete but you
know it imagining existed for a lot has
existed for a long time
and roughly I'm going to follow this
instantiation strategy that I'm going to
take any terms that I get in my formula
and I'm going to instantiate the
universal variables using that ok and
that's similar to unfolding as well so
here are the main contributions of this
work right we explore various logics
like pure fuzzy logic first row logic
with background theories and first row
logic with recursive definitions and
show the completeness of formula-driven
term instantiation for some of these
fragments fragments of these logic and
in particular for first-order logic with
background theories right we have a
fragment called the safe fragment what
that admits completeness right and we
can show that the verification that we
are doing kind of falls in that class
modulo recursive definitions right once
you get rid of recursive definitions I
will tell you how right it kind of falls
in this class and this roughly explains
why natural proofs are actually so
powerful because I actually complete in
the in that sense the second thing we
have is that we will not have
completeness results for first-order
logic with recursive definitions it's
clear that you cannot build a complete a
complete procedure for for first-order
logic with recursive definitions right
and so we mitigate this using using
certain techniques right which are
related to invariant synthesis as well
right and so it seems to be a new kind
of way but a lot of people have been
doing this in the theory improving
community already I think what we're
doing is we're doing it in the first
order context right so that we reduce
this
first-order reasoning work for which we
can prove completeness okay
so first a reminder of classical results
and I'm sorry if you know this very well
it's just that I've been with audiences
where they may not remember it so first
of all first order logic admit sound and
complete reasoning there's a good with
completeness theorem right first logic
is undecidable right and validity your
first order logic is re because it
admits the sound there has a complete
proof system you know that you can
enumerate proofs and prove any theorem
in first order logic right so the
validity is in re and satisfiability is
not nari because it's not decided all
right and it also turns out that
recursive definitions and least
six-point cannot be expressed in first
order logic right and there is no
complete procedure for first order logic
with least fixpoint if you throw in that
you can do non whole thing or something
and then show that you cannot have an re
procedure for it and so first order
logic with least six point in a full
generality they cannot be a complete
procedure for it right you can't hope to
prove every theorem so but but for
first-order logic right building
complete decision procedures is
theoretically possible right you can
just enumerate proofs and if you have
your axioms and eye exams enumerable
right which they are typically even for
the background theories right you can
just keep on enumerated through proofs
and they will sign it at some point but
it's not useful in practice you know you
know you're not going to do this so we
are not interested in any you know any
operation which will prove which will
have been complete it's clearly true
what we want to show is quantify
instantiation which is particularly
useful in seems to be particularly
useful right whether that is complete
now though I just now said it should be
possible there's actually a fundamental
problem of doing this with verification
logics right and because a considerable
logic for verification conditions that
is powerful enough that it's undesirable
okay
now unlike first sort of models the
models I deal with in verification are
finite and enumerable right the
programme configuration is not an
infinite object it is a finite object
right it can have integers it can have
unbounded integers but still it's finite
right and any sort of finite structures
you can enumerate so I can enumerate all
models which means satisfiability of the
problem in of the logic is an re right
so validity cannot be an re okay so the
fact that these models are finite means
validity becomes harder right and I kind
of lose the lovely thing I had in for
sort of logic that validity is actually
you had a complete procedure for for
validity for first-order logic I cannot
actually take it down to program
verification so what's that buck finding
is easy yes yes
so so you this is why you can you get
you can you can test but you can't you
can't verify so it all depends on your
axiomatization so I'm looking at early
first-order logic so if you wanted four
sequences you have to eczema ties it in
for service or logic could be a me in an
infinite eczema transition but it should
be in recursively enumerable one right
so pianos met and Pressburger thematic
for example is a infinite oxidization
yeah I mean in program verification it's
finite right I'm just saying that
infinite things are actually easier than
finite things for proving validity right
but we don't have infinite things here
so there is inherently a problem in
building complete engines for
verification
here we'll come back to this sorry
fractals is fine
fine an area of infinite if we don't
throw that in verification but I don't
know about fractals and the theory so
she has a simpler setting which
first-order logic no recursive
definitions and no background Terrance's
pure first-order logic is qualify
instantiation complete and it turns out
that it is so so first consider pure
first-order logic and we're going to do
refutation based so she will negate it
and show unsatisfiability
first we skolem eyes and we remove every
all existential quantification by
replacing it with functions right and
then we do systematic formula-driven
term instantiation right so create an
intuitively growing conjunctive
quantifier free formulas wherein every
time you you you replace any universal
quantifier quantified variable with any
of the terms that are current in your in
your in your formula so far okay so more
precisely let's say we want to show we
have some kind of finite axiomatization
a1 through a n and let's say it's
universally quantified and I want to
show fee or not fee is implied by it
right so i negated that i so i have this
formula to show it's unsatisfiable right
then what I do is I start with fee the
thing which I want to prove under the
exhibit ization right and every time I
take the the universally quantified
formulas and I instantiate it using a
term in my in in what I had before right
next n right so at every time I get
quantifier free formulas right and X
star is the Union if I go on forever X
star is the union of all of them okay
and indeed it's true that this is a
complete procedure if I generate X n
iteratively and I check right whether
it's satisfiable if it is unsatisfiable
there will be some point at which i halt
and find it to be unsatisfied there's a
combination of her burns theorem so
herbin theorem really says that you can
always build a universe with only your
terms
once you Scala Mize you can only build
it with your
right and you need to what we had to do
is slightly modify it because this is
really driven by the formulas that you
have it's the instantiation is driven by
the formulas so you're you to kind of
prove it again and then compactness so
with Herman theorem you really get X
star that the set of all things will be
on Sat and then by compactness theorem
for first-order logic right we actually
get that at some point X and it must
hold
okay so quantify instantiation works
really well for first-order logical okay
now let's move to many sorted first
order logic right so this is a setting
which we had to define because this kind
of best fit our disbelief for that but
I'm not sure maybe we can take it
offline so so here I have a full ground
universe right so I have many thoughts
right I have a foreground universe which
is
uninterpreted and have a background
theories that are interpreted so this
could be arithmatic
sets whatever you will write so I have a
set of background theories but it's very
important that these thoughts are
completely disjoint right and what I
have is a universally quantified formula
right over over over this over this
vocabulary right and I have
uninterpreted functions that kind of map
across these cards and a rough idea is
that I'm going to model my heap here
right these locations are modeled here
and maybe a function from here to
integers will tell me what data is
stored there right a function from a
pair of locations could tell me the heap
let that is contained that that that is
can that is characterized by that list
segment or some data structure and so on
so roughly this is this is going to be
my the logic that I this kind of
uninterpreted world the program
configuration that I'm looking at but
the contents of the program
configuration in terms of primitive data
types are going to be kind of captured
using
the background here is now so this is
the world we want to belong to right and
then I want to take this formula which
is only universally quantified the
outermost quantification is only of the
foreground universe because I will want
to talk about my program configuration
using Universal quantification and
internally I could have more
quantification which is in the in the
respective theories right let me just
allow that but the outer corner fication
is on the foreground and now i could ask
the same question right I could fix some
some theories and and I could say I
could do quantify instantiation right
and when I do quantify instantiation
these these variables will be replaced
but I'm not going to touch also cow
right so I'm just going to do quantify
instantiation in my foreground universe
right and I ask whether that term
instantiation is actually complete right
now the background theory is if I had
the axioms for them I could do
instantiation using those axioms as well
and then everything will be complete but
I don't want to do this I really want to
use black box solvers here so I don't
want to start in San shooting here right
arithmetic should be solved by an
arithmetic solver and it turns out that
this is not true that's right
there are simple examples that
demonstrate this but quantify
instantiation just doing blindly on the
foreground is not going to be complete
and the reason is that the background
theory can actually restrict the
foreground theory in ways that are you
know that that will preclude you from
finding a proof if you just looked at
the terms that you get by instantiating
the foreground so there main technical
result we have is that quantify
instantiation is complete in the setting
for what I call safe formulas of safe
fragment and this is very easy to
understand what the say fragment is so a
term is called foreground guarded the t
naught is the foreground universe so a
term is called foreground is foreground
guarded if it can
Dane's variables only of the foreground
sort and a formula is safe if every sub
term that you have is guarded right
which basically means that you cannot
derive a term in the foreground universe
right using using functions over Kwan
Yew niversary quantified variables in
the background universe you can't say
there's a list associated with you know
or a location associated with an integer
you can go the other way around right
but you can't or you can't come back to
the right so essentially under your
fragment doesn't have background
theories typically but it is true we can
prove there yeah so if you have two
sorts it will allow yeah right we can
prove as a corollary the UF thing as
well the punishment figure class as well
yes so there are two simple restrictions
that you could follow to meet this
fragments conditions one is not to have
functions that go from from the
background sort to the foreground zone
if you don't have any functions there's
no way you can construct anything
anything wrong right if you had only
forward functions then it's fine the
other way is to know have no explicit
universal quantification on the
background zone if you say I won't
qualify over integers explicitly then
also you're fine because then you're not
going to generate this when in practice
what you found is that the VCS that we
generate on heaps actually meet both the
conditions you need to meet only one but
it meets actually both the conditions
right you don't need to qualifier
integers right you quantify all the
elements of a list and then you can look
at the keys associated with that but
you're still using a forward function
and you're not quantifying over four
integers
so if you want to say that to list
service right same what Abdullah's you
wanna say to you was yeah so you'll have
a length function which is recursively
defined now we can't define length with
first order logic yet but then you would
say that the the length of these two
functions are the same that's fine
length is a function which goes from
nodes two integers right so Ares will be
done differently you'll have foreground
universe of area names let's say a or
whatever then you'll have a function
that map's a and an index to some value
and that's okay so you can have your
domain can be a cross product of any of
the universal it's right that's fine but
your range has to be always a background
one
so now ray can be defined this way as
well index yeah to say a value location
of values right so that's right
that's fine because the location is not
a background oh if you have it if you
have a pointer than a true pointer is it
like an integer thing that's harder I'm
talking about here pointer locations
being abstract locations so B so J but
we're using an array in this another
array yeah you need you can do that too
but yes so you can yeah but you don't
have to use your guide to the same way
you you but you can't do it where you're
using your way content as
you don't write it that way you can
model it differently so that so you
still yes so so I'm wondering I don't
want to go into the proof of the main
theorem where I'm going to look at some
ramifications right one is that if you
do not have any quantification of the
background theory then term
instantiation gives you only quantify
free formulas right and over the
background Theory you know if they are
nice and they have their Nelson open
combined able then you can actually have
a decision procedure and this decision
procedure not a district procedure
complete procedure right the complete
procedure will just do this repeat till
it's unsatisfiable do one more level of
term instantiation and check whether
that that set of instantiation holds or
not right and gives this actually gives
you a complete procedure for the say
fragment now the first thing which we
had when we had this result is that this
must be wrong alright because surely if
I have a background theory of natural
numbers I can define lists finite list
and therefore recur in only six points
easily using arithmetic as a background
theory right so I can have I can say
Anil is a list its length to 0 and then
a non nil element is a list if the next
of X is a list and that is one length of
X is now one more than the other one
right you can define what you're doing
is you're using using recursion but now
you're piggybacking your recursion on
the background theory which supports
recursion right but then this actually
goes wrong right because it lists with
numbers is you know incomplete right you
cannot build a decision a complete
procedure for it right so it will
contradict a completeness result if you
can actually do this okay so what is
going on it turns out that the whole
thing has got to do with non-standard
models all right it turns out that
Pressburger is magic though it's a
completed somatization
right admits non-standard models and
your reasoning only with respect to a
background theory and not a background
model right you don't have a true model
you only a background theory so I could
have you know this kind of a list right
where X is X reaches and I can claim X
reaches nil but it doesn't reach in any
finite time right and to justify it I
could have the length function map X to
a non-standard element so non-standard
elements
non-standard arithmetic is where you
have your normal natural numbers and
let's say you can have a copy of Z after
that okay and it turns out that you
using first-order logic you cannot
distinguish between that and just
natural numbers right but you think that
nonsense model I can actually create one
which doesn't have finite length and so
you're encoding attitude of curing
machines to show incompleteness all
it'll break down so it's actually in
fact complete and the completeness
result does hold and doesn't contradict
out here so now we also get a kind of
understanding of natural proofs right
formulas given in
first our logic with Lee six point right
let's say this is the definition right
now what you notice is that if I gave
you something with the least fixed point
definition and you just did unfolding on
it then really you do not distinguish
you know you're not capturing the least
fixed point semantics at all right when
you unfold if all that you're doing to
do with your recursive definition is to
unfold it then what you're really
treating it as is and if and only if
operator right the fact that is the
least fixed point is kind of lost
because you never you never said
anywhere that you're going to use it or
that way okay so so you can look at
natural pulses actually doing two things
one is replays these fixed point
definitions with an if and only if right
now this is semantic loss right you're
not expressing these fixed point right
and Phase two is doing quantify
instantiation which is essentially doing
a loop recursion definition unfolding
and what we now know is that this is
actually I'm going to argue now that
phase two is actually complete okay and
remember for completeness we need safety
right so I'm going to argue that what
we're actually generating is safe so it
turns out that when you model heaps
right you have locations nodes in the
foreground universe your pointers model
as uninterpreted functions in the
foreground universe you have data stored
in data structures that those go from
foreground to background like a key
stored in a data structure right
recursive functions and all are from you
know like sets of keys and a data
structure in a binary search tree would
be from foreground to background heap
let's our foreground to background and
recursive definitions like BST our
predicates which are you know defined
using these other functions but are
still predicates on the foreground which
aren't interpreted my question still
applies sorry
if I have an array with indices indices
are integers of their background right
still I have a function from the
background theory to the contents of the
array which is program so it's array
cross integers to integers
no no array crossed integers to
something in the foreground like values
to values so we're not doing point we're
now doing locations as to locations that
you can do pointer arithmetic on the
abstract locations to pools right this
will have a function from array across
integer to pairs to trans something in
the foreground right huh what's the rule
that doesn't seem to respect this okay
so maybe I have not I'm not thought
about that maybe it's true it's possible
so in the natural proof work we don't do
that we don't have arrays we you deal
with purely recursive data types right
and that's the context which I'm saying
that this is true so arrays we we do
consider in the paper but that's only
for the decidable fragments we also get
decidability results on the way so there
might be things which we cannot model
yet
so here lists of lists yeah but the
point is have I mean again you're not
doing arithmetic on it but you're just
doing so so these are actually safe
right because you have only four one-way
functions and you don't need
quantification on the on the on integers
typically right so it's actually safe by
the other condition as well and so we
actually have this term instantiating
that that we do for natural proofs in
that work is actually complete right
because it belongs to the say fragment
provided you have replaced least fixed
point with fixed point definitions so
this is this phase is actually complete
right and there is a semantic gap
Institute introduced in phase one so why
can't we prove things right so we
naturally there are lots of simple
things we cannot prove and the user has
to give exams for it but in a word
usually it turns out that if you define
two data structures the way to the
relation between them is typically not
provable and you actually give that like
else egg XY and you have a disjoint list
Y then you get list X if you unfold
you'll never be able to prove this
theorem right and it turns out that the
reason is the phase one that semantic
difference is the one and again non
standard models is the reason why you
get into this problem right there are
the the reason why you can't prove it is
because it's not actually true in the if
and only if semantics of of list
segments and lists right there's a
semantic gap between least six points
and if and fixed-point
semantics right so this is actually you
know if you had X I can even though it
never reaches Y right this is the next
relation right never reaches why I can
declare X 2 and Y to be a least segment
as long as I declare all of these to be
least segments list segments
karana can still do that and there's a
model for it so we couldn't prove it
because it wasn't valid in the first
order world
so non-standard Motors crop up all the
time in this work we found problems in
the literature and PhD theses and so on
so there was not they were they were
theorems which are now actually again
open because of this I won't comment on
this stuff around shape analysis logics
with the reachability predicate is is is
assuming elesif its point semantics
right and so you are extracting somehow
yes over that so what does your abstract
ethics point in not at least fixed point
so when you're doing unfolding you think
I can only is all these logics of
certain restricted forms of heat for
which you can have complete looks right
so I'm trying to like how would so he
has instructions for his classes in
logic so I wonder so just wonder what is
between all this stuff newly and well
then gang have done where they basically
don't have any background theories but
they have been just very hard problems
because of reach ability right but those
fall into your other class of be
increasing where you're using credit
logic fragments I see so I mean I think
there ought to be a name for this
phenomenon but it's harder you push on
the decidability boundary more
idiosyncratic or Luva c'mon old stuff
okay so I think I'm running out of time
so is that correct so I want to tell you
a little bit with fixed points because
what we have essentially done is remove
Li six points and said everything works
well but what with Lisa Lisa Lisa points
and and then the idea is that how are we
going to prove these things after all if
we are not going to do this unfold and
match right so this brings to this other
part which is so remember that first
order logic will be six point cannot
have a complete procedure right so
anything that you introduce is going to
be look like a heuristic right and what
we do is we introduce induction
principles right that bridge this gap
between six least fixed point and fixed
point okay we do this kind of uniformly
systematically guided by the formula
that we want to prove okay obviously
this is got to do with invariant
generation as well because a program is
just you can look at it first or logic
with these six points the entire program
right and so you're proving now that
whole program is correct without loop
invariance now right so you're actually
generating loop invariants by doing this
induction principles so so we the the
crucial thing is that we have a stay
within the first order logic framework
right
induction principals are typically
second-order right but you want to kind
of stay stay in the first order logic
framework and in some sense we're
instantiating the formulas that we want
to declare our inductive systematically
so we have some in the paper right so so
I just give you one right one is this
for every X if I have to show that R of
X implies sine of X where R is has some
definition Phi R there's a recursive
definition which is using least fixed
points okay and then what I do is
introduce this inductive induction
principle which basically says that the
partial fixed point of this operator
right
if if if sigh right if the the what I
want to prove right is a prefix point of
the definition of R then R implies fine
okay this is essentially saying that
whatever I want to prove I'm going to
prove that inductively based on the on
the on the definition of our right I'm
going to show and formally this becomes
a prefix point right so if I can show
the size of prefix point of Rho Rose the
definition of our right then R implies
society I mean that is true right and
this brings in the least fixpoint
semantics into picture right but the
induction principle is completely
first-order there's no mention of these
fixed points there are slightly more
general versions in this paper but the
most important thing it should show is
the C that is guided by the formula that
you want to prove you write it as this
form that this recursively defines
object implies something else and then
you you generate this automatically and
then the introducing the deduction
principle in turn leads to other
induction principles to be added so you
will add one induction principle like
this one and then this might have
something else and that will introduce
you if you regroup it right you can
write it you can see it of this form and
you will you can instantiate one more of
another kind right you can kind of keep
going and actually some examples
actually require that let you do that
and then what we showed is that all the
things that we could not prove in
natural proofs right all the things
where the user needed lemmas right
before the user needed to give lemmas to
help it to prove were all proved using a
couple of these induction principles
okay so these are the two many accents
right there were about 150 programs but
these have got to do only with the data
structures and not with the programs
right and and there are simple things
like if the binary search tree then it's
a binary tree right you can't prove that
using unfolding right
yeah what has a couple of papers in this
yes so so that is correct sir that's in
the CLP framework and right so there's a
little separation logic right right so
the key thing here is that to do it in
the first order logic framework right so
that once you do this you know you can
build a complete procedure after that
right we also tried it on some programs
which are not to do with the heaps like
yes exactly I mean the same thing we did
he addresses the same thing so we we are
we prove some things like McCarthy 91
for example it's it proved it in two
iterations it was able to find the right
loop invariant right and actually prove
the correct so so this is what emerges
right if you want to do natural proofs
then one thing is to take first order
logic with least fixed point which i
think is a good logic to work with right
replays least fixed point definitions
with with fixed point definitions right
but but use induction principles to
bridge this gap otherwise you're not
going to get the power you need and the
second phase is you know unfold and do
quantify instantiation and this part is
in fact complete right you must ensure
safety along the way so I don't know
what the array of pointers will work
right but this is only if you can ensure
safety is there is the completeness
result true okay and if you further
ensure that the resulting formulas when
you when you instantiate terms are
quantify free then you have the ability
to use assembly solvers with various
theories and you will combine because
they quantify free and by Nelson open
they will combine so you have a you have
something which should work fast right
it's worked faster than the settings we
have tried but in general it should work
first okay so that's it so conclusions
Anoop theorem that proves completeness
of term instantiation for multi sorted
uninterpreted combination of theories
for the safe fragment and then the
systematic introduction of first order
induction
in suppo principles that were seem to
work in some settings at least and I
think what these to right we have an
understanding and robust reformulation
of this completely ad-hoc strategy that
we were doing which is take everything
right Express and first or logically
Sixpoint just unfold it seems to work
right and it seemed to work was was
gotten from proofs where people who are
writing and we thought you know you know
there are such simple proofs why don't
we use them right so but now I think we
have a more robust understanding of what
exactly's happened okay and there is a
paper by gay and demora and this is
actually very similar we found it after
we did this paper but it's very similar
and very different at the same time so
the the basic difference is that the
it's not a multi solid universe right
and then the logics that for which you
can prove such a theorem become very
restricted right you can't even take you
universally quantified variables and
check equality between them right
because equality is not an integral
symbol right and they won't allow that
right and in fact you can't really the
proofs all different even the first
theorem that I said for first-order
logic being complete without any
background theories even that doesn't go
through if you if that setting so and of
course there's a huge amount of work in
finding induction principles in the
theorem proving community is he l2 did a
lot of work right we're probably
mimicking such strategies in the first
order logic world right and what we do
have is this completeness thing and
reduction to SMT and using SMT solvers
so future work I would like to build you
know SMT like solvers being efficient
solvers for first-order logic with least
six points right I think there's a lot
there be a lot of applications because
first are logically six point is
incredibly powerful right the second
thing is we don't know what this
induction principles for how do they how
will they work for programs that do not
involve heaps we don't know it's
probably easy to try it on
and see how it works but we were a
little surprised that McCarthy did not
take like 100 iterations right it just
took two iterations and out popped
invariant and that was a little
surprising so we should investigate that
and of course how does it compare right
because all these are going to be
incomplete techniques right how do they
compare with other techniques such as
interpolation would be good to know
the third thing is I I think first order
logic with least fixed point and
background theories maybe the right
logic to do for hostile reasoning or
deductive verification right we
certainly need this much power right we
need data structures and also in general
we need this kind of power to do have
expressiveness of the of the weakest
free there's a paper by Blas and Gotha
which actually that a long time back
that argues that we actually should do
this because you don't need a rithmatic
you don't have to show something
complete by mapping everything to
arithmetic with the addition and
multiplication for which you don't have
any solvers anyway right that's how most
completeness proofs go right but
actually with first-order logic and
least fixed point you can get that power
to express the weakest pre of any
program including loops right and that
will maybe is useful right and and we do
have now some ways of handling
first-order logic with this fixed point
automatically the third thing is we
probably don't need much more I'm not
sure about that I'm little hesitant to
go beyond first-order logic because I
just don't know how to deal with
automation beyond first-order logic and
I don't have compactness I don't have
completeness I don't know term
instantiation I know nothing to work
with so it's going to be very hard to go
beyond first or logic at least for me
right so so maybe this is a good logic
to to to work with thank you
[Applause]
so right so you Stern about talking
about the importance of decidability and
mostly what you said was actually about
completeness and so so what about
decidability another reason if I have
completeness I don't necessarily good
counter models and if I'm actually doing
a proof you know counter models
interactively the counter models are
very important you know we use them for
refining inductive hypothesis and we use
them when things are going wrong and we
have to understand why so under what
circumstances can I get kind of get
caramels
I think counter models you could do by
symbolic test input generation right you
could bound your heap you could bound
things and then get counter models it's
just that I don't know whether program
configurations are intended to be finite
so there should be a finite counter
model well maybe once I sort of
abstracted into the logic now I know
without abstraction I'm just saying when
you just pool of you see you could you
could try for I hope you don't want
non-standard models it's account example
right so I'm just saying that this
normal symbolic execution should do
counter models become tomorrow's to the
obedience yeah but that's right I don't
want to compromise my program I want to
counterbalance my VC yeah sure I'm
saying it's not same thing yeah call
tomorrow at the OVC you could you could
you could do because I've done
abstraction when I've got to my clinic
like babies yet but I've structured for
example I got rid of you know these
fixed point semantics or whatever so if
my lot if I send my VC into my their
improver and it should either eventually
come back with a proof or it should
eventually come back with a counter
model I just think that these two
procedures might be totally different if
you want to prove something versus fine
count examples these may be different
things right because we cannot possibly
target finding complex counter examples
and finding simple proofs at the same
time right so
I think you're missing my claim of the
usefulness of counter balls okay I'm not
saying that I'm just saying that you can
do counter models by some other
technique well what if I know know if
you could do that then your logic would
be decidable and because if I can get
counter models right if counter models
are REE and if crew sorry Gustav not re
they're gonna have these six point
they're not going to be on right but
let's say I've thrown away the least fix
my semantics then it is completely this
is disciple yes I agree in fact I'd
argue that you know all your VC is I
mean the program configurations are
innumerable it's satisfiability is inari
so if you've done away with this
[Applause]